give up something to get something and I
thought I didn't have any money so I had
no phone
I painted my windows black so I didn't
know if Sun was up the Sun was down all
I knew was I had to write and I wrote
and I wrote it it was very bad it wasn't
good at all but every day it was getting
better and better like like a machine
like a muscle until finally the idea for
rocky came so the idea is you must fail
a hundred times to succeed once it's
that's part of it you know one succeeds
the first time it's learning how to not
get disappointed with failure to
understand tell you you only learn when
you fail you don't learn we you succeed
but we fail that's what you learned so
that's how I learned by lucky I was a
failure in New York and that is the
reason I started writing which may be
successful I had to teach myself early
on expect to fail expected covenant
welcome it is going to happen but don't
it's not a permanent state somewhere
along the line you changed you stopped
being you you let people stick a finger
in your face and tell you you're no good
and when things got hard you started
looking for something to blame like a
big shadow let me tell you something you
already know the world ain't all
sunshine and rainbows it's a very mean
and nasty place and I don't care how
tough you are it will beat you to your
knees and keep you there permanently if
you let it you me or nobody is gonna hit
as hard as life but it ain't about how
hard you hit it's about how hard you can
get hit and keep moving forward how much
you can take and keep moving forward
that's how weird it is done now if you
know what you're worth then go out and
get what you're worth but you gotta be
to take the hits and not pointing
fingers saying you ain't where you wanna
be because of him or her or anybody
cowards do that in that ain't you you're
better than that
you just watched two amazing clips from
Sylvester Stallone take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]